my name is sam devine i'm 27 years old
and i am a salon owner my story of
becoming a hairstylist was pretty
interesting
i had been cutting hair
all throughout high school and all of my
friends and playing and just having a
good time and i never actually thought
about it as a career path because it was
never brought up to me that it could be
a career path and i'm reading this
article and i was just like
you've got to be kidding me somebody is
charging 800 for a haircut that's crazy
and she's doing every celebrity and she
was just it was incredible so i went
home and i did a lot of research and i
found out that she was not the only one
and that you know that she wasn't like a
fluke situation
and i decided right then there i was
like i want to that's what i want to do
like that's definitely what i want to do
so i'm at my salon in this small town in
new jersey and i'm talking with my
stylist i was like hey like this is what
i want to do
i have no idea where to begin and she
was like you have to go to videl sassoon
hands down when you become a hair
stylist you have a couple different
options you can open your own salon
which
some people choose to do
you can go and work as depending on what
state you work in because every state
has different laws but a lot of states
allow booth renting which means that you
will come into a salon location they'll
they'll have stations set up and you pay
rent essentially a monthly rent for a
station or you can work in a salon
that's commission based which means
you're part of a team you're part of a
culture you're part of the entire
business when you're just starting out
in the industry you're gonna have to
essentially like earn earn your way for
a little while you're gonna have to
prove yourself if you would have asked
me a month before i decided that this
was what i was going to do i would have
told you you were crazy i would never
open a salon i knew absolutely nothing
about running a business or how to start
a business or
anything related to business other than
showing up at work doing my clients and
you know collecting a paycheck
so
for me it was a lot it was a lot of new
learning but luckily i do love to read
and i love to learn new things so
at google was my best friend i googled
absolutely everything endlessly looked
uh looked up every absorbed anything i
could read about opening a new business
whether it was a hair salon or not just
figuring out you know what that entailed
my responsibilities on any given day is
going to be getting to the salon making
sure that everything
is ready to run smoothly so making sure
that the schedule is correct making sure
that we're fully staffed taking care of
the bills
making sure that you know payroll is run
and payroll is processed working on my
own clients
for a good portion of the day